[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt bei uns gerade das wetter wieder
richtig schön zeit zum grill okay wie
grillen auch wenn das wetter nicht so
schön ist aber wenn die sonne da ist
dann wird man umso lieber heute gibt es
einen kebab rezept vom grill und zwar
habe ich mir da jetzt eins aus dem
türkischen kochbuch ausgesucht aber
madonna kebab kennen vielleicht viele
von euch das gibt es auch beim türken
vielleicht darauf die türkei besucht und
zwar so dass diese langen großen
scharfen kebab spieße also wir machen
jetzt heute eine große menge denn das
ganze team ist mit deswegen brauche ich
jetzt zwei kilogramm fleisch ein halbes
kilogramm fett das habe ich jetzt
einfach separat gekauft bzw abgetrennt
denn der fettgehalt im camp ist wirklich
wichtig damit zum einen das spiel gut
hält und eben auch wegen dem geschmack
dann brauche ich noch vier zwiebeln vier
rote paprikaschoten dies sind nicht
scharf 4 knoblauchzehen salz und pfeffer
chili kreuzkümmel und ysop ihr sorgt das
wird auch unfaire genannt ihr sollt es
einfach eine bestimmte art von chili die
müsst ihr nicht nehmen könnte aber
nehmen die es einfach richtig schön
schwarz also man sieht schon und zwar
ist es eine chilischote die wirklich so
lange gereift wird oder auch so lange
gereift bisher dunkel ist und durch den
bestimmten trocknungsprozess an der
sonne wird es eben schön dunkle nacht
wird dann nochmal eingepackt und
fermentiert auch wirklich richtig lange
chiliflocken habe ich jetzt auch aus
unserem garten die getrockneten daher
nicht so viel denn unsere trainees mal
mega scharf und ansonsten gibt erstmal
nichts zu beachten bei der paprika nehme
ich jetzt hier die kerle raus die
zwiebeln und die knoblauchzehe kann ich
schon mal schälen und jetzt braucht ihr
gleich entweder den fleischwolf oder
einfach ein richtig scharfes messer
denn das hackfleisch wird selbst
zubereitet
[Musik]
knoblauchzehe am besten ein bisschen
zerdrücken und dann lässt sie sich
einfacher schälen krise steigen wieder
in die augen
ich versuche immer zu verhindern und was
geht nicht also der taucherbrille mit
nase dran jetzt wahrscheinlich das
gemüse ist es erstmal vorbereitet ich
schneide noch grob denn das kommt bei
mir auch gleich einfach in den
fleischwolf damit aber durch die öffnung
gleich passt aber zuerst kommt das
fleisch durch das fleisch ist einfach in
lange strenge schneiden
so kann es den fleischwolf besitzer
kleiner also nicht in kleine würfel
sondern eher länglich
[Musik]
jetzt hier auch noch das fett bis hin zu
kleidern bei einem kleineren also bei
einer kleineren passion würde ich jetzt
auch mit dem ball einfach fein hacken
aber ich nehme es nicht leicht den
fleischwolf denn die riesenmenge dann
stehe ich auch übermorgen noch da daher
nehmen wir gleichen fleisch dazu machen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier vorne am fleischwolf
eine etwas grobe scheibe also nicht ganz
fein und kann jetzt hier das fleisch
verkleinern
[Musik]
gar nicht stopfen sondern wirklich hier
oben er rein gleiten lassen um die
schnecke im fleischwolf die packt sich
dann diesen langen strand und zieht dann
durch
also da muss man sich gar nicht drücken
auch im sudan fed dazu geben da mischt
sich auch gleich
[Musik]
das ist das letzte stück und jetzt kann
ich hier hinterher direkt das gemüse
durchgehen
so bekommt ihr nämlich auch alle
fleischreste gut raus ihr könnt auch
immer ganz gerne wenn jetzt was wieder
noch frikadellen machen wollt noch
semmelbrösel hinterher machen also
einfach altes boot durch geben
dann bleibt einfach nicht zu einem
fleischwolf hängen nämlich aber gleich
doch den job kosten dafür nicht zum
stopfen sondern eher zum anschieben
[Musik]
der fleischspieße bringt nicht immer nur
ein fleischwolf also als auch ein bruder
gemüse verteiler im englischen meister
und nicht gleich sondern alles da
kleinere also seid ihr euch gut für
veganer geeignet weil man kann damit
verlassen machen und gemüse frikadellen
und alles tritt sie kommen jetzt alle
gewürze rhein-erft da wirklich nicht
sparen mit den gewürzen chili gebe ich
jetzt wie gesagt erst mal nur wenig rein
weil es mein eigenes gezüchtetes chilis
und es ist wirklich sehr scharf
ansonsten hätte ich jetzt hier acht
esslöffel chilli rhein gegeben also dass
man vielleicht vom zu erkennen weil es
nicht ganz so scharf ist alles schön
verkneten
[Musik]
jetzt die masse fertig wir sind
natürlich ein bisschen weich dadurch
dass sich die paprika drin habe und die
paprika eben auch so nass war
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt
gern business semmelbrösel dazugeben ist
zwar jetzt nämlich sogar mit original
aber ich finde gerade wenn man die
frische paprika dazu nimmt darf man sich
da gerne etwas helfen oder einfach
vorher die paprika entsaften das geht
auch aber das war jetzt glaube ich ein
zu großer aufwand
deswegen muss es hier und dann nehme ich
eine kleine menge raus und brachte die
schon mal an damit ich schauen kann ob
es vom gewürz verpasst so macht es auch
wenig rebellen macht zum beispiel
entweder in einem kleinen schälchen und
dann kurz in die mikrowelle einfach das
hackfleisch durch ist oder kurz in der
pfanne anbraten und dann könnte nämlich
probieren ob salz pfeffer die schärfe ob
alles passt das jetzt kurz in der
mikrowelle
[Musik]
also ich finde es geht noch bis ende mai
ein tolles niklas es wegen den kindern
und da kann jeder selber mit chili druck
ja
ich habe jetzt hier diese riesen aber
später die könnt ihr nehmen oder ihr
nehmt einfach kleine mann habe das
schöne kleine portion und ich finde die
auch ganz wichtig ist einfach nur das
flache spieße sind die etwas breiter
haben damit das ganze eben auch gegrillt
werden kann also diese dünnen holzspieße
eignen sich dafür nicht und was dann
ganz wichtig ist vor dem grillen einfach
die spieße einfrieren
ihr könnt sie wirklich auch super
vorbereitet daher damit man wie bei
burger bands das ganze erstmal fest
bekommt und sie beim grillen dann
auseinander fallen ob ich nicht ein
bisschen sonnenblumen in die hand jetzt
machen wir erstmal einen kleinen
spiesberger partie ist meine stockach
und dann werden sie wie bei burger
pettys einfach eingefroren damit unsere
besser grillen kann jetzt nochmals einen
kleinen spiels ein bisschen öl in die
hand nehmen spießen und schön flach
drücken
[Musik]
das erste blech ist fertig und wandert
direkt ins gefrierfach bis es
eingefroren ist das mache ich noch den
rest fertig hin und sehen wir uns gleich
wieder am grill
wir sehen uns vorher nicht bereiten auch
zwiebel sarrazin und macht nebenher noch
ein fladenbrot studie freier mann
ich mache gerade abschließen
dieses höchst professionell aus schatz
invasion kebab meister verloren gegangen
würde schon fragen
[Musik]
das brot aus dem backofen die spieße
sind im gefrierfach hier mache ihr song
zwiebeln salat ich habe die zwiebel
jetzt bereits fein gehobelten fein
geschnitten
hier kommt petersilie dazu ordentlich
petersilie dann viel zitronensaft und
etwas olivenöl salz pfeffer und zu
maximal bis er sich beim gewürzt das
passt auch perfekt und dann haben wir
gleich die perfekte kombination draußen
[Musik]
unser feuer draußen ist gleich bereit
wenn ihr aber nicht draußen grillen
möchte sondern lieber zu hause können
sie es natürlich auch offener
grillplatte hier tun oder ihr nehmt
einfach eine pfanne in der pfanne geht
es auch ich mache so sehr auf der
grillplatte da komme ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen eingefettet da kommen die
gefrorenen spielte drauf und erst
nachdem die unterseite eine schöne
kruste hat werden sie gewendet damit
einfach das spiel nicht kaputt also die
weiß wie beim burger braten wie beim
pattinson auch erst mit kruste bilden
lassen und dann wenden
[Musik]
trittin war es natürlich einfacher zu
grillen aber hier draußen geht es auch
gott also drin namen ist sie sich auch
perfekt drehen lassen
ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt auch
genau so groß
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die riesen schwer brauche
endlich gibts ja dann extra bonner grill
dafür dass man die man schön drehen kann
dass die nicht anbrennen wichtig ist im
prinzip nur dass der grillrost das credo
ist der große wusste dass es ein
bisschen gefettet ist aber das ist ja
auch die aber der liegt nicht genau wie
viel genau das ist gut so da kann ich
dir schön wenden
was soll man kann das rein und das nicht
weil könig kann alle zum essen kommen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen gleich alle nach draußen
zum essen wir probieren schon mal also
ein bisschen brot also eigentlich macht
man es in der türkei man nimmt sich so
spies da kommt einfach hier ins brot und
zieht einfach ab geräten ab und dann
zwiebeln salat dazu gehabt jemand
abziehen
ich liebe seine filme ist so cool aus
und jetzt doch immerhin ein bisschen
kartoffeln rein gar nicht aber geht ist
nicht weiß es die man noch mal ein stück
stadt sie verlangt ja ich hab's auch
nicht scharf gemacht wegen der l und
wegen samira so also fleisch ist
wirklich hier das fleisch kommt und wie
schmeckt meist gut
das problem bei mir die lsd nichts mehr
übrig habt doch alle flaschen kann
grillen megane coole sachen ja da hat
sich wohl jetzt unser westliches team
jungs mädels ihr könnt alle kommen und
dann wird es gleich gegessen probiert
das rezept unbedingt mal aus und
schreibt neuer feedback
bis zum nächsten mal ich habe
[Musik]